the movie is set in 1975 in a Cambodian
city named Phnom Penh after the Vietnam
War the Americans have finally pulled
out of Phnom Penh which was a neutral
zone the residents of the city are
thrilled and are hoping for a better
life with no fear of violence amidst the
people celebrating as a family of nine
named the lungs the father paw is an
officer in the National armed forces and
is a wealthy man taking good care of his
family the protagonist is the middle
child loong an ambitious young girl
still learning to live life the lung
family enjoys a regular day in their
life unaware of what life has in plan
for them outside the people are
celebrating the end of the war and
restoration of Peace in their City what
they do not know is that the Communist
Party named kimer Rouge is planning to
attack the city taking advantage of the
shaky political state it is in an army
of the khmera Rouge interrupts the
celebration
urging the people to evacuate their
homes immediately like everyone else the
young family has to pack the essentials
and leave behind everything they have
worked for to avoid retaliation the
Cambodian troops are stripped out of
their clothes and seized of their
weapons this gives the Communist group
full control of the city and its
residents as refugees thousands of
people make their way to the camps in
the countryside in hopes of finding a
safe home the young family also gets
inside their car and joins the crowd
after half an hour of driving they are
stopped by one of the rebels who asks
them to leave their vehicle behind he
claims that it will slow them down and
will be more useful to the soldiers who
are protecting the city pa'ang knows
that they are being robbed but has to
oblige to keep his family safe further
along the way the rebels start
separating the commoners and government
workers they don't want the government's
people in the refugee camp to avoid any
spies paw is nervous because if they
find out he is in the National army
forces his life will end short hence at
night when no one is watching he throws
his State card into the fire a confused
loong catches him in the ACT but doesn't
say anything like her siblings she
doesn't understand the depth of the
situation thinks that they will return
to the warmth of their home in a few
days three tiresome days later when
their Journey still doesn't end loong
abruptly stops in her tracks upon being
questioned by paw she claims that they
should be home by now the man decides to
be honest and tell her that they won't
be home anytime soon but he wants her to
believe he will keep her safe no matter
what a few hours later they reach a
checkpost where the soldier sees all
their belongings loon sees her favorite
dress being thrown into a basket and all
the money they have is taken away
according to the rebels they are
starting a new rule in Cambodia where
class doesn't exist money won't be
necessary and everyone will be equal
Paul lies about his profession to not
get caught while he watches some of his
colleagues being taken hostage because
they used to work for the government by
that afternoon the family finally
reaches the countryside and sees how
opposite it is of the lavish life they
were living in the city one thing that
catches lung's eyes is the respected
monks being forced to work in the Paddy
field just when the little girl starts
to panic they see a familiar face in the
crowd their Uncle Lee who is a farmer in
the countryside has come to help them he
takes them to his house allowing them to
stay with him and start a new life let
alone comments that her uncle is poor
upon seeing the house in turn her father
makes her understand that their family
is poor too which means that they will
have to live differently a few days
later loong overhears the elders chat
and finds out Uncle Lee supports the
Communist group who he thinks will save
them from the Americans she is unsettled
that he supports the people who kick
them out of their house but doesn't say
anything the very next day their family
is asked to find Refuge somewhere else
because if the rebels find out paw was
in the Army Lee's family will also get
into trouble the youngs understand that
height situation Lee is in and pack up
to go to the nearest refugee camp they
are picked up by a car in the middle of
the night and reach the camp by the
morning they soon find out the camp is
like a prison with strict rules that the
Communists think are revolutionary first
they are asked to dye their clothes
black to represent them being on the
same level as everyone else next to the
girl's hair is cut and they are
separated into groups to do heavy labor
all day the refugees of all ages work in
the field planting grains and vegetables
for hours but when it is time to harvest
the rebels get all the food while the
refugees are left with scrapes one night
loon witnesses an execution of a fellow
Refugee who used modern medicine to cure
his dying son instead of the medicine
the regime approves of after two months
of living in such a condition the family
is weak and growing sicker then one day
it is announced that the Communist army
fighting throughout the state needs help
all of the young refugees are asked to
join the force including the three
eldest young children a difficult
goodbye marks the last time the family
will ever be together now with only her
parents and three siblings Loom feels
like her life couldn't be worse but
little does she know what the future has
in store for her life goes on as usual
with the kids working 10 hours a day in
the field with no food or water during
harvest season loon's sister is caught
sneaking a single Bean in her mouth she
is beaten and berated for the mistake
but fortunately for them the rebel
doesn't tell the camp leader at night we
see paw pouring a handful of rice into a
pouch he collects some every day to
ensure his family will have something to
eat when push comes to shove the family
roasts crickets for the night and eats
them imagining that they are eating the
chicken soup their mother used to cook
that night long dreams of enjoying her
favorite ribs and in a moment of frenzy
eats the rice stored for emergency in
the morning her brother hits her for
doing so but paw takes her side and
caresses her lovingly as days go by the
family gets bad news one of Young
siblings had died in a bra loon watches
her mother break into sobs and remembers
how she used to be before life took a
turn the death takes a toll on the
family but before they recover they are
met with yet another hurdle paw is
called to the city to fix a broken
bridge everyone knows that once he
leaves the chances of him returning is
nil the parents share a tearful goodbye
as the kids watch them not understand
the severity of the situation that night
loong imagines her father being killed
by the rebels they throw him into a pit
filled with corpses and she sheds a
single tear coming to terms with the
fact that she will never see him again
man and I thought Air Bud was a sad
movie a few weeks later the children are
given no food for two whole days to feed
The Starving Children the mother takes a
risk and tells them to steal food from
the garden but the plan ends horribly
when loon's brother is caught and beaten
having had enough the mother asks them
to run away and find other camps with a
Better Living environment the kids are
supposed to go separate ways and tell
people that they are orphans their best
chance at surviving is if they never let
people know their real names and do as
the rebels say in the next hour the
children each pack a picture of their
family and leave their mother and
youngest sibling behind when the Sun
rises the three come across a beheaded
statue of God that has been peed on by
the rebels they pray to the Statue
before loon's brother separates from her
and her sister starting a journey of his
own a few miles later the girls bump
into a group of soldiers who show them
the way to the nearest Camp upon
reaching there loon finds out it is a
camp for children where they are taught
about communist propaganda she and her
sister lie about their names and start
living with the other children since
they are now treated as future Rebels
their diet and lifestyle is better than
how it was before instead of training
the entire day they are given fixed
timetables and kept disciplined the head
Soldier notices that loong makes friends
easily and has the spirit of a fighter
hence she is transferred to a camp away
from her sister where children are given
military training loong learns to fight
shoot and create mind traps through the
training one day she is allowed to go to
the other Camp to meet her sister for a
few hours taking the opportunity she
packs up food in her scarf and instead
heads to the original camp in hopes of
meeting her mother however to her
surprise the camp and her home are
deserted she imagines her mother among a
pile of bodies and her little sibling
crying later a lady informs her that the
soldiers killed everyone who is weak and
took the remaining refugees away no one
knows where they went and even if the
mother is alive loon cannot meet her in
the end the little girl helplessly
returns to her Camp the same night the
camp is attacked by Vietnamese shelling
loud noises and explosions wake everyone
up
urging them to flee into the woods many
young children die unprepared for the
real war loong's first priority is to
find her sister but she is unable to do
so amidst the chaos eventually the camps
are destroyed and the civilians flee to
get away from the war the next morning
everyone is on their way looking for a
safe place to stay to lose surprise she
meets both her siblings and the three
share an emotional reunion after hours
of walking the people finally reach a
temporary refugee camp managed by
Vietnamese troops the injured are
treated with modern medicine and are
helped by the Vietnamese even though
they are from the opposite side the
children make friends with another group
and decide to rest for the day however
their relief is short-lived when only
hours later the camp is attacked by the
Communists in retaliation the innocent
civilians flee into the woods but come
across the mines planted by loong and
her friends during training lung sees
innocent people die in explosions and
blames it on herself the site stops her
in her tracks and makes her rethink
about everything that has happened to
her in that moment the young girl learns
that violence has stripped her of her
childhood and she will do everything she
can to make her life better in the
following scene the brawl has ended and
the refugees are building a camp of
their own they have managed to capture a
communist terrorist and are humiliating
him publicly for what he has done young
loon cannot help but feel bad for the
man as she sees her father in him the
people leave the prisoner to die in the
Sun but she stays with him for a long
time thinking about her family and
comparing his situation to theirs the
scene cuts to a few weeks later life has
been better for the siblings since the
rebels were defeated by the Vietnamese
troops one day the two older brothers
who survived the camps come looking for
their family and the siblings reunite
one more time the final scene shows us
the present day when the young children
have all grown up they are incredibly
grateful they were able to survive in
such a harsh environment the movie ends
as we see them pray to a group of monks
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching